this isn't a skydive gone wrong these
guys want this to happen also they can
go faster
are they crazier than the ordinary
adrenaline junkie obviously but it's all
for an official competition what's
called the national championships of
canopy piloting and this sport also
known as swooping competitors fly just
inches above the ground at close to 100
miles an hour depending on the challenge
at hand they then try to jump as far as
possible
kind of like the long jump or land in an
exact place like skee-ball a key part of
canopy piloting is limiting the effect
of the parachute on the way down
that's why jumpers pull a 450 degree
spin to keep their speed up it's an
extremely technical sport that punishes
even tiny mistakes
top supers are used to injuries from
broken bones to torn ligaments to more
broken bones but when they get it just
right
there's a mix of elegance and adrenaline
that's hard to beat